c'était à la salle, entre
autres, maltraitance, baisse,
manque de soins, tout ça a été
corroboré,bobobobobobobobobobob.
- Là, on a la preuve,
on a vraiment la preuve...
- Brigitltltltltltltltltltltltle
qu'a vécue sa soeur en septembre
dernier, alors qu'elle était
résidente aux Floralies
de Lasalle.
BRIGITTE LAVOIE,
- Elle n'était pas propre,
n'était pas lavée.
- Après avoir été placé sous
tutelle par Québec, l'enquête
confirme les cas de maltraitance
résidences des Floralies
de Lasalle et Lachine.
SONIA BÉLANGER, ministre délég.
à la Santé et aux Aînés, Québec
- Les conclusions de ce rapport
inacceptable.
- Marques de violence physiq
et de déshydratation chez
plusieurs résidents, manque
insalubrité, gestion déficientet
dans ces établissements pour
au groupe français Vivalto
depuis 2019.
- Le rapport m'a fait penser à
fois, parce qu'il y avait
des centaines de lits.
- Impossible pour la minisévévés
son arrivée à la têtedes résiden
s'est améliorée.
Mais l'inquiétude chez
les familles des résidents
demeure grande.
- Quand le CIUSSS est arrivé
ici, ça a beaucohahahahahahahahs
vont partir à un moment donné.
- Ça vous inquiéte?
- Oui. C'est pour ça que je suis
allé voi- - - - - - - - - - - -e
la tutelle restera le temps
qu'il faut, et que les
gestionnaires de CHSLD privés
même si aucune sanction contre
les propriétaires des Floralie
n'est sur la table
pour le moment.
- Je pense que la conséquence,
ils la vivent actuellement de
En fait, il faut comprendre que
les résidents soemememememement
en administration provisoire.
- Des inspections surprises,
l'embauche de personnel,
des formations et une meilleure
coordination font partieananana.
Mais la confiance s'effrite
devant l'histoire qui se répète.
PIERRE LYNCH, Assoc. défense de
- Dans le passé, on a eu
beaucoup de recommandation
comme ça, là. Mais le problème,
c'était dans l'implantationlelet
habituellement communiquées,
mais on réussit jamais à toutes
les implanter.
- Surtoui i i i i i i i i i i is
n'ont pas été apportés
malgré les visites répétées
du ministère.
Radio-Canada, Montréa